[Music]
someone said memories are like time
travel to the past
and dreams are time travel into the
future
well
we have definitely traveled into the
future
a lot of people said
building a hundred plus cubic quantum
computer was just a pipe dream
we wouldn't get there until decades from
now
and here we are
out of the crazy ideas of quantum
mechanics
this
this real thing
in just 10 years
such a fantastic example of this
scientific method
hypothesizing testing inventing
experimenting with all the ways to make
cubits how they could work and how they
could look
and also how often you're gonna get
stuck
there's so much history in these cubits
charlie bennett and ralph landauer got
us all started on this
asking things like is there a
fundamental limit to the energy
efficiency of computing and is
information processing thermodynamically
reversible
only the kinds of things that a
physicist would ask
i remember going to see our first
quantum laboratory
and
the modesty
what the laboratory environment looked
like
but the enormous level of risk
and difficulty of what was behind the
scenes of that modest laboratory
our first quantum device and quantum
system
and the basis of all our future quantum
computers
certainly i'd say one of my fondest
memories involves studying this one
actually a single qubit system that we
had back then the effective temperature
that this device exhibited was far
higher than what the fridge temperature
said it was
we've tried numerous experiments over
years to try to address this but
nothing really seemed to work very well
the community started to get a sense
that maybe there's some other radiation
blackbody radiation that might be
causing this we took this idea back and
we shared it with one of our engineers
jim rosen
and he didn't believe it at all he
actually just uh said i'm going to prove
to you that this is baloney
so he did something really really
drastic took the entire package and he
bricked it into this what we call echo
sword material it's made out of the same
absorptive material that you find on
stealth fighters it's literally a one or
two pound almost looks like a
paperweight almost a very heavy object
and said okay cool this down and see how
it looks amazingly it was 10 times
better than what we had before went from
500 nanoseconds to 5 microseconds
easily the the the highest coherence
time we'd ever measured at ibm
i remember calling at the time
uh our group lee mark ketchum on the
phone we were blasting loud music in the
in the lab just really really excited
that we saw this and
we told jim hey look we proved you
exactly wrong
[Laughter]
the engineer said i've never been more
glad to be wrong
jay and jerry's idea to put a quantum
computer in the cloud was
brilliant it showed people it was real
the boldness of saying what felt like a
laboratory experiment is going to be
available to all of you now
i think it started by realizing that our
colleagues needed this tool
to do their research what we learned was
certainly that there was a huge appetite
for accessing cloud deployed systems i
mean within the first few weeks there
were people running algorithms that
first year we started to see exactly how
much
research was starting to be generated
what the community uh was was bubbling
into you know that was fun itself you
know finding
the first like quantum trolls on our
little community forum but you know it's
where we basically saw that this has so
much legs in terms of expense and and
who wants to use this and who wants to
learn from this it changed how we looked
at things completely
the field was enormously focused about
what we could do when we had
the so-called perfect quantum computer
but now
we had generation after generation of
new capabilities
she had remarkable algorithms but all of
those were designed with this perfect
machine in mind
but now we had these devices that were
being made available they were smaller
they were noisy so how can we
benefit from them that was the time when
the team did the simulation of beryllium
hydride which
back then was the largest chemistry
simulation that was ever done on a
quantum computer it taught us about
the promise for scaling
and it really opened the door for
exploring more applications in chemistry
more applications from physics you know
it's the same as the city is the mother
of invention
we are so bound by how
we see the world and how we experience
the world
but how many people realize that when
they're using a quantum computer they're
going into extra dimensions
extra dimensions are always presented as
such a science fictiony thing
but the mathematics of quantum mechanics
is very clearly multi-dimensional
this abstraction in mathematics is how
nature operates
it
sounds like science fiction but it's not
it's just science
all right we're starting to get our
robbie data coming in here let's take a
look see if we see any of that look we
just reduced yeah they are all looking
about right here
everything so far you could have done
with a classical computer
we already knew the outcome of every
experiment
[Music]
but now
we actually can't predict what the eagle
will find
[Music]
let's take a look
um
yeah most of them are pretty well-lined
some of them are little questions
appearances are looking pretty good too
uh is it alive it's like all 127 cubits
are alive all right congratulations
if you want to understand what these
quantum computers with more than 100
qubits can do
the only way
is to use them
[Applause]
today
i am excited to present to you the first
commercial quantum processor to break
the 100 cubit barrier
meet eagle
our new 126
cubic chip
for the first time in history
we've entered the realm where a
classical supercomputer can no longer
fully simulate the behavior of a quantum
chip
eagle will let us explore truly
unchartered computational territory
2019 brought the 27 cubit falcon
processor
which introduced the heavy hex qubit
arrangement arranging qubits on the
edges and corners of hexagons allowed us
to reduce errors caused by interference
between qubits
in 2020
we were able to build hummingbird
or 65 cubit device thanks to
multiplexing
that's the ability to read out multiple
qubits with a single wire
which greatly reduced the number of
components that needed to go inside of
the fridge
eagle incorporates both of these
advances and also takes advantage of
ibm's deep expertise in chip
manufacturing and packaging to set the
stage for scalable quantum computing
even the quantum processors packaging is
important for scaling quantum chips
traditionally require a tangle of wires
that have to be directed outward to the
edge of the chip
but state-of-the-art research allowed us
to incorporate 3d integration into eagle
this allowed us to put chip components
and wiring on multiple physical levels
that make the path towards a 1000 cubit
quantum computer possible
next year the ibm quantum team plans to
release a 433
cubit processor called osprey
and in 2023
they plan on debuting condor a 1121
cubit processor
condor will be an inflection point
it will allow us to explore error
correction and dive even further into
the realm of quantum advantage
everyone always talks about the number
of qubits which is definitely important
for running more complex calculations a
qubit count
scale
is just one facet of the way we measure
a quantum processor's performance
eagle represents improvements that will
allow us to press forward on all three
of our performance metrics
scale
quality and speed
for improved quality eagle uses the
latest advances in qubit fabrication
control electronics and software that
will help us maximize its quantum volume
for increased speed eagle will
seamlessly integrate with classical
computing workflows
using kiskit runtime and other
improvements to maximize the number of
quantum circuits it can run per second
it's important to continue to develop
the software systems to match the
hardware advances the open chasm 3
assembly language is already allowing
developers to run circuits incorporating
both classical and quantum instructions
we plan on developing new circuit
libraries tailored to fields like
finance machine learning and chemistry
making it easier than ever for
developers to incorporate quantum into
business workflows so
what can we expect from this step into
unchartered computational territory
we hope to use eagle to explore the
realm of quantum advantage
where quantum computers can tackle
problems faster and with fewer resources
than classical computers
and quantum advantage might be coming
sooner than you think
by integrating quantum with our
classical high performance computing
resources we will have a powerful
combination that will open an entirely
new path to study physics chemistry and
machine learning
the past 10 years have shown how
fundamental scientific research has
created a potentially paradigm shifting
advance in computing
but what do the next 10 years have in
store
we dream of a future with frictionless
quantum computing
where users can code a quantum computer
without having to know about the
intricacies of the quantum processor
we envision developers across all levels
of the quantum computing stacks relying
upon our advanced hardware with a
cloud-based api working seamlessly with
high-performance computing resources to
push the limits
but developing this larger system poses
a challenge
we believe that eagle is the last
processor that will fit inside
of our ibm quantum system one
and so we are excited to unveil a
concept for the future of scalable
quantum computation
the ibm quantum system 2.
[Music]
system 2 is a bridge to the future of
quantum computing
ibm quantum engineers took a holistic
approach and will be capable of housing
the upcoming 400 and 1000 qubit
processors
and even processors we haven't begun to
develop yet
system 2 takes a hexagonal form
this scalable modular structure will
allow us to bring fridges close
together it will give flexibility to
design even larger quantum systems
by linking processors together
system 2 represents a glimpse into what
the future of quantum computing looks
like a true quantum data center
by following this roadmap we think that
by 2030 companies and users will be
running a trillion quantum circuits a
day
and we hope that quantum computers will
be providing real world benefits
solving some of the world's most
important problems
[Music]
i want to thank you ibm summit attendees
for joining us on this journey over the
past 10 years we have made tremendous
advances thanks to you
our global community of users and the
ibm quantum network we hope that you'll
stay with us for the next 10 years and
beyond as we continue to transform
computing together
[Music]
you